i just know from a little boy falling in
love with this game to where i am now
and this
love has grown further i've put a lot
into it
and i've got a lot more to give so with
that being said
never had any doubt that i wouldn't be
here that this deal wouldn't get done
and be right for the both of us and be
right as i said for the organization
and everybody invested so i'm just
thankful
as dak prescott from earlier today he
never had any doubt that a deal would
get done with the cowboys he's the only
one
who didn't have doubt they pushed it to
the absolute limit
and shireen he waited and waited and
waited and waited and
almost pushed it to the point where the
cowboys didn't give him the kind of
offer that would have caused a long-term
deal to be done and instead would have
started the clock in motion toward his
final season potentially
with the cowboy so it's easy to say now
that it's done
that he never had any doubt that it
would get done he should have had doubt
that it would get
done and that's because he was as
firm as determined and as relentless
with jerry jones as jerry jones would be
with someone else that's where dak won
he'd never blinked he never gave in and
he got the contract and now it's
official four years 160 million
celebration for dak prescott questions
though for the cowboys going forward
with that much money
soaked into one player yeah
no question mike and they also talked
about all the money they have invested
in the offensive line
at receiver at running back a lot on the
offensive side and really dan quinn's
gonna have to build on that defensive
side with what he can get
frankly because they're not going to
spend money over there aside from what
they've already spent on demarcus
lawrence but
you know i was interested in what jerry
was going to say about this being the
hardest negotiation he's ever done
because i think we all believed that
because dax stuck to his guns and said
i'm not going to be talked into this by
jerry jones and steven jones i'm not i'm
not going to be talked into it
i'm going to wait i'm going gonna trust
my agent and he did that he did that
last year and he got a great deal
we've all said that but jerry just
talked in circles when he was asked
about this being the hardest negotiation
he had ever done so we really didn't get
the answer we wanted
out of him but at some point i'd like to
ask him more about that about this being
such a hard negotiation because i
guarantee you mike
the cowboys never thought it would go
this long it's been over two years now
so basically jerry answered that
question the same way he'd answer
pretty much any other question talking
in circles talking about circumcising
mosquitoes
and fortunately today not getting into
any
barnyard activities that would be
illegal in many jurisdictions okay uh
they they definitely did blow this and
they misread
the room and i know for a fact that they
were astounded
by the resolve that dak and his agent
had and this gets back to something that
we've said
the past two days as it relates to other
quarterbacks who are going to be in a
similar situation you need to have an
agent
who will keep you from pouncing on an
amount that seems like
it's sufficient when in fact it's not
when you have
other friends family members teammates
other people other agents who are trying
to drive a wedge between you and your
agent and that happens all the time
saying what are you thinking what are
you doing you should take that deal you
know there were other agents last year
when dak suffered the broken ankle who
were basically gleeful
that todd france hadn't done a long-term
deal because it's like see you should
have done the long-term deal well
who's got the last laugh now even with
the broken ankle
four years 160 million and no
protections no
issues no limitations that would keep
dak from getting that money if the ankle
was still a problem he said today the
ankle
will be fine he'll be good to go and
surely we were talking about dr cooper
yesterday in his cowboy hat
he's taking a close look at this ankle
every other doctor down there is taking
a look at the ankle and come to the
conclusion that it's fine
or they wouldn't have done this deal
yeah he had a great quote mike about
being ready to jump up on the stage and
and
jog and said i don't think you guys were
ready that for that but he was ready for
that so
he does think it's healed now you know
ask for a timetable when he'd be a
hundred percent he didn't allow that he
said the one thing i was
gonna not gonna do from the start is set
a timetable on this when i'm gonna get
back but when it when it's time to be
ready
i'll be ready and he also talked about
mike taking a lot of inspiration from
alex smith he said alex smith went
through the same thing only
worse and he talked to alex smith and
really took
inspiration from alex smith so you know
he learned something from alex smith and
came back and has gone through his rehab
and by all accounts
he's doing fine in that and had the
clean up surgery in december and should
be back to healthy
maybe not for an off-season program if
they have any sort of off-season program
but at least by training camp he should
be back and good for the cowboys mike
let's hear directly from dak prescott
himself regarding
current status of that ankle as he works
his way back
to 100 i'm ready and i'm getting close
i feel good you saw me walk out here i
can do a lot of things that
um that i obviously couldn't do weeks
ago and even days ago that i'm doing
today
so it's hard to say that i'll be ready
in this time or that time but
i'll be ready when it matters and i'll
be more than more than healthy and
better than i was before
amazing to think that that investment
was made without
knowing with certainty with 100
certainty
that he'll be good to go but that's
that's the risk they're taking
and it's a huge financial gamble
but it's a gamble and i also saw
that dak resented the fact that people
basically suggested he bet on himself he
gambled on himself well
he did he did let's not start start
developing alternate facts on what
happened here
he did bet on himself he did reject the
offers that the cowboys put on the table
and went with less money and a one-year
deal last year
he could have had much more security
last year
at the time that ankle broke he didn't
have it
he did gamble he did wager and hey
i've supported him every step of the way
but don't start acting like it's
something that it wasn't guys
you did gamble and you won and don't act
like you didn't and i know he doesn't
want to run
anyone's face in it but you did gamble
and it worked out well
yeah and he also talked about mike that
he owed it to other quarterbacks he owed
it to other nfl players to do what he
did to hold back to not sign anything he
didn't want to sign that
todd france's agent recommended he
signed so he waited
and he did gamble and he did win despite
the ankle injury in week five
he won on this mike and he won really
really big
one of the best contracts in nfl history
i think you've called it
and so he did the right thing by him and
the injury didn't affect him at all
it's not one of the best it's the best
to have only four years of a commitment
and to have the highest signing bonus
the highest one-year payout 75 million
the highest full guarantee it's signing
and do not have to tie yourself up
for six years or maybe even longer doing
a six-year extension on a deal that has
one year left this is the best deal
because it pays him more money than
anyone's ever gotten
at signing and it lets him get back to
the trough in four years or sooner we
talked about that yesterday
probably we'll be back in three years
because the clock will start ticking on
the cowboys once we get into the 2024
season and once we get through that he's
free and clear he can go wherever he
wants to go he
ha and i want to address the issue that
he owed it to other quarterbacks kirk
cousins made that argument
although a lot more clumsily a few years
ago
when justifying his refusal to accept
the long-term deal
from washington and there is a benefit
to other players
but let's not make this about altruism
but baloney
this is about capitalism and it's great
that you can spin it with a straight
face
if your dak prescott into saying i'm
doing other quarterbacks a favor
and in a roundabout way that's a slap at
the tom brady's of the world who don't
stretch the rubber band as far as they
can so others can come in
behind that amount because think of what
happens what's happened with the
patriots and what surely is happening
with the buccaneers this year
hey tom brady's only making x who do you
think you are why do you think you
deserve
a premium when the quarterback's not
making a premium well in dallas
that argument's out the window the
cowboys have given the quarterback a
premium and all other quarterbacks are
going to be looking for that same
premium so yes
there's an incidental benefit to other
quarterbacks but come on
he he i this is i'm getting irritated
the more i hear about what he said today
because it's being characterized as
something other than it is
it was a money grab and that's fine
that's fine and i guess you don't want
to get
to the press conference and say it was a
money grab but it was a money grab and
he also said it was never about the
money which is the ultimate proof that
it was
always about the money and why shouldn't
it be about the money it's about getting
compensated fully and completely
for the risks you take the sacrifices
you make and the abilities that you
develop
you've got god-given abilities you're
working to their maximum level
that's what you get paid for that's what
the fans are showing up to watch and
paying their money to see and that's
what people are tuning in to see so
there's nothing
wrong with that but i look i guess i
guess they spent some 160 million
shireen on a pr
specialist who fed him a bunch of crap
to say today
that doesn't mesh with reality well and
and he also said i'm happy to be a
cowboy for life well
that certainly isn't what this is are
you dying in four years
yeah right that is not at all what this
this is this is to get back to the table
in three years or at worst
four years and get even more money so
there's nothing about
being a cowboy to the end yet now the
greatest cowboys in nfl history only
played for the cowboys in their nfl
careers i realized danny white started
out in the wfl
but the danny whites tony romo's roger
stahlbach troy aikman they all spent
their entire careers with the cowboys
cowboys expect dak chriscott to be there
long term to be there forever in his nfl
career but nothing is forever when you
have a four-year deal mike
it's a four-year deal period in the
story he'll be back at the negotiating
table soon enough
maybe he means metaphorical cowboy for
life because only a true cowboy
could pull off the kind of heist that he
pulled off
with the nfl's version of black bart and
jerry jones so
maybe that's what he means because
you're right it's four more years
maximum and then they're gonna have to
do it again so
it's it's it's and again i don't expect
that he's going to disrespect jerry
jones at this point i don't expect
that he's going to get up there and and
brag and boast and crow
but let's let's just let's not
pretend this is something other than
what it is it
is exactly what it always was and now
he is a cowboy for four years and it'll
make 160 million along the way
and you know sharing i want to get your
thoughts on this we talked yesterday
just kind of in spitball fashion about
amari cooper likely entering his last
year with the cowboys
i've looked at ezekiel elliott's
contract over the next couple of years
and sims and i talked about this today
on pft live
zeke's salary for next year
2022 12.4 million
i believe that becomes fully guaranteed
this month
now the 9.6 million that he's due to
make this year is already
fully guaranteed there's nothing they
can do about that but what zeke did with
his contract and this is the smart way
to do
the triggers for full guarantees you
don't wait until
the year the money is going to be earned
you have the trigger the year before
which makes it harder
to cut the guy because if they let him
walk away now and avoid the 12-4
in 2022 they still owe him the 9-6
this year that money's already vested
that vested
at signing of the contract or last year
at this time at the latest
and the more sims and i talked about it
and i've been
scouring the rosters and i've been
brainstorming
and i've been trying to find the one guy
the one guy
who gets cut and possibly traded but
maybe cut
that we're gonna say holy crap we
we never expected that sims thinks that
zeke
could be the guy who gets the plug
pulled on him you got any thoughts on
whether or not that happens
this year not next year but this year
yeah
well it's not going to be surprising to
me if they do it
i will say this i think they would go to
him
and try to tweak the contract
restructure the contract somehow some
way and i
that very well could be done i think
they like zeke they like what he brings
the offense they like the leadership
that he showed last year he was voted
the good guy award because he really
stepped up in
zack's absence uh and filled in in that
leadership role so they saw a lot of
growth in him over the last year i don't
think they're ready despite the salary
despite what it's going to be next year
fully guaranteed if they don't do
something here but it
i would be i think they would go and try
to
change his contract some way mike before
they
cut him and i will i will i said i
wouldn't be surprised if he's cut i
think i will be surprised if he's cut
this year
i won't be surprised if they tweaked the
contract some way
well but if they go i changed my mind in
the middle of that
but but he says no i got 9.6 million
fully guaranteed this year you want to
cut me i'll go somewhere else now to be
an offset obligation in there
because i never heard there is no offset
and when there is no offset language in
a contract like this it's big news when
the contract comes out it's hard to get
a term like that
but if dak or if zeke excuse me would be
cut
this week at some point before next
wednesday at 4 p.m eastern
then yeah whatever he would make
elsewhere this year
the cowboys would get that dollar for
dollar credit and
he'd he'd essentially be playing for
free this year because no one's going to
pay more than 9.6 million
on the open market for this year um so
it's just something to keep an eye on
and another thing that occurred to me
today
and this is one of the problems with
and look jerry's been the gm of that
team for over 30 years so i guess you
figure it out in time but i feel like
when you have ownership also running
personnel and you start drafting really
well
making good decisions about who to pick
and develop those guys you have a
coaching staff that gets the most out of
them
i almost feel like they're more
compelled
they feel more obligated for their own
pride for their own
vanity for their own ego to keep those
guys
just so they can continue to say we
found him we drafted him
we developed them and made that that
does that you know because look at what
they pay to mark cooper after they gave
up a first round pick to get him 20
million a year on a five-year deal
look at what they paid zeke when he held
out look at what they're paying back now
the problem is they waited too long to
decide to pay him
look at demarcus lawrence i feel like at
some level
they they still need protection from
themselves because
these players that they've drafted and
developed basically become trophies that
they don't want to part with
and you got to pay them to keep them
yeah they let byron jones go last year
and i was actually kind of surprised
that they let him go because he was
their best corner mike and though
so i figured they would overpay to keep
byron jones
and they didn't but we've seen it
repeatedly with jerry he players he
likes and he thinks are really good
and her core group of players for him he
likes to keep him and
and they don't walk away very often when
he when he really wants to keep him he's
never lost a player that he truly wanted
to keep
they didn't have a salary like demarco
murray he said
hey we're only playing demarco murray
this if he
takes wants more than that he can leave
but for players he truly wants to keep
he's never lost a guy
and so you know i wasn't surprised they
got this that contract done
but it cost them what cost them in debt
because they didn't get it done two
years ago but it cost them with other
players they shouldn't have given
zeke the contract they gave him they
shouldn't give amari the contract they
gave him
and at some point mike they've always
pushed money down the road right they
restructured deals and pushed it down
the road at some point that comes back
to bite you a little bit and
maybe it has a little bit in the past
but at some point they're going to get
bitten by that
they're pushing some more down the road
our colleague josh alpert texting during
the show that
tyron smith and zach martin and lyle
collins all restructuring their
contracts
that's presumably the simple
restructuring that means
you take the compensation from this year
turn a lot of it into a signing bonus
spread it out over multiple years
the only benefit from kicking cap
dollars into future years as the cap
goes up
those dollars relatively speaking have
less impact because
dollar for dollar percent by percent
they mean less because you've got more
dollars
you can spend and this is the year a lot
of teams are going to be kicking those
dollars forward
because the cap is down 15 million and
the cowboys by the way saved 15.4
million they
in in doing the deal with dak and
dropping his anticipated cap number from
37.6 to 22
to they basically offset
the drop in the salary cap just with
that one contract but they still have
other business that they need to do
and they still continue to believe that
they are the cream of the crop
in a division that has largely been crap
especially last year a sub 500 team won
it
both stephen jones and dak prescott said
that they're absolutely the team to beat
in the nfc east and i don't expect
anyone
to say anything different than that this
time of year this is all about optimism
and the glass is half full even if the
glass is 90
empty but the thing about the cowboys in
recent years and yes they've delivered
from time to time but it seems like
every year
on paper they've got a potential
championship team
and then when it's time to go play the
games something happens last year i
thought they were going to be the one
seed
in the nfc and they didn't even make it
to the playoffs so i don't put a whole
lot of
stock in the big talk and i know it's
for the benefit of fans who want to hear
that stuff
at a time of the year when games aren't
being played but
you know we we've seen it and heard it
enough times
for me it just goes in one ear and out
the other shireen
yeah and we still have a long way to go
mike and free agency in the draft i mean
what's washington going to do at
quarterback i mean they could end up if
they get deshawn watson do you
not think they're going to be the
favorites for the division certainly
they're probably going to be the
favorites for the division
going forward so we'll see what happens
but let's you know look at the cowboys
since 95. we know that's the last time
they went to the super bowl last time
they went to the nfc championship game
since then they're four and ten in the
postseason with ten playoff appearances
so they've really
struggled mike in the postseason getting
to the postseason
back in his career is one and two in the
postseason so he has something to prove
there
if he's going to get more money the next
time he goes to the negotiating table
and the folks at points bet agree with
the cowboys they are the team to beat
-105
favorite gotta bet 105 to win a hundred
everyone else is in plus territory
but that's the way it is every year
there's still that that
shine on the helmet the silver helmet
with the blue star
it's america's team and that's always
going to make people view the cowboys
differently there's always going to be a
greater sense
of anticipation and there'll be a full
slate of prime time games
for the cowboys this year and they know
they'll have dak prescott this year
and for at least three more years beyond
that the question is how many more years
beyond that
will it go and you make a great point
desean watson could end up being
in washington the eagles could take a
quarterback with the sixth overall pick
who ends up being great
the giants who knows what they're gonna
do in free agency there's too much that
still has to happen
between now and week one of the regular
season and then
the factor that always affects how a
season goes
it's injury we know they're going to
happen we just don't know when
to whom and for how long the guy is
going to be out but the cowboys season
down the crapper last year once dak
prescott broke his ankle
well i'm not saying it could happen to
him again i don't like to name names
because i don't want to be accused of
jinxing anyone
but all it takes is one key injury
and everything changes i remember the
year
when the 49ers played the buccaneers i
think it was 97 were you on the bucks
beat then
97 it was on the bucks bait then it was
90s remember
seven yes was it 97 when warren sapp
grabs jerry rice's face mask while rice
is running to reverse tears his acl
and that's that and that and that
changes everything that was back when
jerry rice still had a lot of gas in the
tank
that changes everything at that point
for the it just gives you a different
feel so you never know when that's going
to happen
that's part of this too but this is the
again this is the time of year where
you want you want everyone to be excited
and optimistic
and we'll worry about wins and losses
when september october november and
december
roll around i still think the cowboys
can be very good i'm fascinated to see
what they do in mike mccarthy's second
year
you know for as much as we'd like to say
now that the prescott the pressure is on
dak prescott or the prescott's on back
pressure either way they both work
the pressure's on dak prescott the
pressure's on mike mccarthy in year two
it's not like they're gonna fire him
after two years but
his his broader legacy was undermined by
the way he coached last year
if he does have dak fully healthy this
year wire to wire with that
40 million a year contract and he can't
get it done
it's going to be another giant black
mark on the resume
of mike mccarthy shireen yeah and you
look at all the coaches mike who have
won super bowls and gone elsewhere
jimmy johnson goes to miami seaford
goes to carolina all those guys we had a
ton of guys that moved around
to second teams after they won a super
bowl even tom flores i mean he almost
didn't get in the hall of fame
because what he did in seattle his
record was so bad so when you go to that
second team it hasn't been done very
often where you can produce and this is
mike mccarthy's chance to show he can
produce but
you know i don't know how long they're
going to give him in dallas jerry
doesn't like paying coaches off we know
that
i think he does get beyond this season
but if they don't get in the playoffs
this season i think he's really going to
be on the hot seat going into 2022 he's
going to have to produce something
or they're probably going to move on to
somebody else as steven pointed out
jerry's not getting any younger and he
only has a certain number of years we
don't know how long that is but he's in
his
upper 70s he's 78 now so you know he's
getting up there where he needs to win
another super bowl if he's going to do
it in his lifetime
watch that guy live to be 98 and and
ultimately win three or four more super
bowls but but you know that's been a
common theme
in recent years i remember when tony
romo tony romo on the bus
right about the time they unveiled the
thing in indian somewhere he was on the
bus and he was joking with jerry and he
said and i think jerry told the story
during one of his sessions on the bus in
indianapolis where all the reporters
come on and hang out with him and maybe
he
maybe he spikes the punch with johnny
walker or blue but
you know he said that tony said i only
got about four years left and jerry you
only got about four years left and uh
you know
jerry's been a good sport about that
reality but there is an urgency there
and we'll see if the cowboys can get any
closer to something they haven't done
since 1995 win the super bowl and also
haven't been back to the nfc
championship game
since 1995. hi i'm mike tarico and
thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports